- Oh my god! Y'all look
fabulous! In your little, like,
suit kind of attire today. It's
like you called each other.
I heard that you were a Texas girl.
- I am, yes! And so are you!
- Is it Euless?
- It is Euless.
- That's so crazy. Yeah,
I'm Forth Worth, Burleson,
that whole area.
- Oh, okay. Yeah, yeah.
- [Kelly] Yeah! Anyway, I
always love having a Texan.
Look it! She's like "fine."
(audience laughing)
Have you been to Texas?
- Yes.
(audience laughing)
- We love Texas here.
Wait, You are a Dallas
Cowboy cheerleader, right?
- I did do that.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Yeah, I did do that.
- [Kelly] Look, I have a friend was a
Dallas Cowboy cheerleader years ago.
And here's my thing about--
- Oh boy.
- No, it's really hard.
No, those girls are so--
- [Leslie] And those girls don't get paid.
- And they don't get paid, that's right.
- They don't get paid either.
- No, you're truly doing it
for the love of the sport,
- [Kelly] Which is kind of insane.
- Which confused me all the time.
- So, people are obsessed with your show.
So, for those that don't know,
so what's your show about?
- Well, the show, it centers
around this woman named Billy
who, on paper, she seems to have it all.
She's a wonderful wife.
She's a loving mother.
She's got two great kids.
But, she just can't stop thinking
about this one particular
man from her past where she was
just wild and free and, and,
- Child, that's that women.
(audience laughing)
- and, and then he comes back,
he comes back into her life
and the whole show kind of
measures--
- [Kelly] Yeah.
will she take a bite of
this forbidden fruit?
- Oh my gosh.
- [Sarah] Yeah.
- I, well, here's the thing.
There was a certain scene,
- I would.
- With a certain man,
and a certain shower.
And it, and it certainly
was seen around the world.
And he, um, this is the
one from her past, right?
- Yes, that's right.
- And, um, it's well, he, he
is gifted. (audience laughing)
below.
- He is gifted from down under.
- Down under!
- He is a man from Down Under
and he is gifted down under.
- Yeah. I ain't seen the
show, but I'll check it out.
(audience laughing) (Kelly clapping)
- So, I have to wonder though,
playing this kind of
sexually charged character,
like this role, has it, like,
affected your real life?
- Yes, it did. You know, I
think one of the biggest themes
of this show is, you know,
it's okay for a woman
to have wants and needs. You know,
it's a very natural thing.
And it's also not something
that we're used to necessarily
seeing on TV. You know,
playing this role, I mean,
she is dynamite in a box.
She is larger than life, this character.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And she really sort of
taught me that if I, you know,
expect my life to look a certain
way or if I have needs and,
you know, that you have to have the guts,
you have to have the guts to
go out there, to get the life
that you want, and to
speak up and to speak up
even if your voice shakes.
You just gotta have guts.
- I think the older you get
too, you start caring less.
It's just like, I can't worry
about what you think about me.
- [Sarah] Yeah.
- I'm worried about what I think about me.
- [Sarah] Yes.
- Like, you know, I want to
like have pride in myself,
in my, in what I want to do in my life.
- [Sarah] Yeah.
- It's just, when you start
liking yourself, actually,
- [Kelly] Yeah!
when you actually start liking yourself,
you want people to treat
you correctly. So...
- [Kelly] Yeah, and you correct them
- And you correct them.
- Yeah. And that's okay.
- That comes with age. Seriously.
- [Kelly] I, I agree.
- [Sarah] Yeah.
- It does.
- Exactly-- Well, hopefully.
Some people aren't.
- [Sarah] You just accept
yourself more. Yeah
(audience laughing)
- [Kelly] We're all on
different paths, remember.